Speaker 1: There's a right wing radio host named
Wayne Alan Root, and he actually used to come on
the show a few years back. He would have these
interesting back and forth with David. But over
the past year or so, he's been most famous for
being adamant in this idea that Donald Trump
should run for Speaker of the House if indeed
Republicans take control of Congress after the
2022 midterms. With the idea there being that
Donald Trump can be the one to torpedo Biden's
legislative agenda. And perhaps be the ones who
oversee impeachment proceedings. If Republicans
decide to impeach Joe Biden for whatever reason
they decide to come up with. Keep in mind that
in order to be the Speaker of the House, you don't
actually have to be a member of Congress. So it's
not like Trump would have to run for a House
seat. He could just be elected by the majority
of the body. If Republicans take control and
while traditionally the Speaker of the House
is a member of Congress themselves, they don't
actually have to be. So a while ago, Root came
up with this idea. He was interviewing Trump and
he was telling him all about it. And Trump said,
you know, that's really interesting. No one's ever
brought that to my attention before. I'll have to
consider it. And it seems like at this point,
Trump just doesn't want to do it either because
it would be too much work or it's just not the
top job in government. So he just doesn't want
to pay any mind to it. So this prompted Wayne Alan
Root to ask Donald Trump about whether that means
Trump supports Kevin McCarthy to be House Speaker
if Republicans take control of Congress. And Trump
didn't want to say that he necessarily supports
Kevin McCarthy. Let's take a look at this clip,
because it really is interesting and it
has to do with this narrative having to
do with Republican infighting. You know, I.
Speaker 4: Was the guy who first brought up the
idea of you running for speaker of the House if we
win in November. You like the idea, but you never
acted on it. You've now endorsed
McCarthy for Speaker of the House.
Why don't I have him running? You know,
I endorsed him in his race, but I haven't
endorsed anybody for speaker. So why not consider?
Speaker 1: Now, that's super interesting because,
of course, we know from that leaked audio that
came out a few weeks ago that right after the
January 6th attacks, Kevin McCarthy was fed up
with Donald Trump. He said that he was ready to
move on from him, which makes total sense because
McCarthy's life was put in danger that day,
as were the lives of other members of Congress
and Mike Pence and congressional staff and
Capitol Police. But then it turned out that
a few days later, McCarthy saw the polling
and he realized that Republican voters were not
so ready to move on from Donald Trump. In fact,
many of them liked the insurrection. So McCarthy
and the rest of the GOP, they had to do a 180 and
go back to groveling at the feet of Trump. So this
means that Trump, who still has, by all accounts,
a hold of the Republican Party, if he decides
to endorse someone else for House speaker,
he's probably going to get his way. And McCarthy
won't have much to say about it. But also, Donald
Trump went on to cite a different reason for why
he's upset with Kevin McCarthy. And I found this
one really interesting. Let's take a look at this.
Speaker 4: We have some great warriors,
Jim Jordan of our group, Jim Banks. We have some
very good people that fight very, very hard.
Unfortunately, a bad decision was made.
This this committee was a bad decision
not to have representation on that
committee. That was a very, very
foolish decision because, you know, they try and
pretend like they're legit. And only when you
get into the inner workings, you say, what kind
of a thing is this? Just a one sided witchhunt.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump is mad at Kevin McCarthy
for not making the select committee investigating
January 6th bipartisan. How about that? And of
course, you do have Liz Cheney and Adam Kinzinger
on the committee, but they can just be written off
as anti-Trump rhinos by Trump and his supporters.
So apparently they don't really counts. This is
incredible to hear, though, because when the idea
of the committee was first proposed, McCarthy and
Republican leadership, they were actually on board
with the idea of investigating January 6th in the
lead up to it, making it a truly bipartisan panel
because they, too, were affected by what took
place at the Capitol that day. But then as time
went on, they decided it would be too politically
risky because it would make Donald Trump look bad,
it would make the right look bad. And so they
just decided we as a party are going to move on
from January 6th and we're not going to have our
members serve on this panel, aside from Kinzinger
and Cheney, who we can't control now that
Democrats, along with these two Republicans, have
moved on and said, okay, we're just going to do it
without you. Then Donald Trump comes out and says,
Why don't we have Republicans on the panel? Why
don't we have representation? McCarthy made a
mistake here. So that really is Donald Trump
for you. If you're working for Donald Trump or
if you're in a position where you're expected to
be loyal to Donald Trump, you're damned if you
do and you're damned if you don't because there's
just no satisfying this guy. And if you do things
right and you're working with them, well, Trump's
just going to take all the credit for it. But
if things go wrong, you best believe that you're
going to receive the blame. And that's exactly the
situation that McCarthy has found
himself in. So that may ultimately
cost him the speakership next year. And
it's kind of funny to sit back and watch.